Valentine's Day is tomorrow so I thought
it'd be cool to invite a friend of the
show who will display some homemade
Valentine's Day gifts and tell us how to
make them she has her own do-it-yourself
YouTube channel some of you may have
noticed she went away for a year she had
some issues but she's back now I'm told
she's fine
so please welcome our friend melody
crafts nobody crafts is here melody what
have you got for us today
hi Conan today I'll be showing you how
to make some homemade Valentine's Day
gift all right well that is great that
is what we're looking for the fun thing
about crafting is you don't need to buy
anything
instead you can recycle existing
materials for example to make this card
I used rope and duct tape I have a large
amount of both in my trunk why would you
have a lot of that in your trunk
remember to decorate the inside of your
card - oh that's nice it's a heart yeah
and it's made of teeth you can get them
at Michael's Michael is my ex-boyfriend
why do you why do you have his teeth oh
here's a cute idea
for this gift I use a pharmacy bag I
found in the trash can outside of your
house Conan okay how do you know where I
live
then I put a meaningful gift inside open
it oh okay is it wait a minute is this
my hair how did you get my hair Oh Conan
you're too funny another Valentine's
gift idea it's to make a booklet of some
of your favorite memories together
Conan this is you leaving your house
this morning
and this is you sleeping who remember
that and this is your feet under the
bathroom stall why don't you follow me
into the bathroom another super fun idea
is to record a personalized message wait
god is that my mom don't worry she's
safe and she'll be fine if everyone does
as they're told you know I'm really
worried about you finally if all else
fails you can get your Valentine a heart
what did you get the heart Oh Conan calm
down it's not human I'm not crazy I
think you need to go away again I should
go away okay well I can't go back there
not after what I did okay
nobody crafts everybody give her a hand
we have a great show host the new Fox
series level masters Lord it's here
[Applause]